und jetzt kommen wir aber endlich zu
unserer nagelneuen rubrik die heute show
macht uns kurz vor der sommerpause noch
mal unnötig schlechte laune es hilft nix
kinder während alles bot noch über
kuroda zu reden
passt etwas denn
ich spiele hier doch auch nur die
nachrichtenlage soll denn das was kann
ich denn dafür dass corona wieder ein
thema ist nur zu gehören hat rund zehn
millionen einwohner aktuell ist davon
fast die hälfte mit corona infiziert
lalalalala ich habe gar nicht zugehört
dpa fünf unicom variante plötzlich
portugals erfolgreichster exportartikel
nach und haltung und auch wenn in
deutschland die inzidenz mit bh 5
tatsächlich hoch gehen ist das
ausdrücklich kein grund zu panik
schließlich hatten wir im gegensatz zu
den portugiesen schon im frühjahr sehr
viel omikron kontakt das macht was aus
andererseits gibt es hier immer noch
über zwei millionen ungeimpfte 60 und
die maske kommt auch rasant aus der mode
in deutschland wer zum beispiel kurz
nach dem einkauf das ding noch auf hat
fällt inzwischen direkt unangenehm auf
die ersten omas denken schon wieder das
wäre ein überfall man wird direkt
angefeindet sogar von exhibitionisten ja
schämen sie sich eigentlich nicht so in
der öffentlichkeit rund gelaufen ist ja
ekelhaft
ja
keine frage mehr normalität ist absolut
angebracht angesichts der entspannten
situation in unseren kliniken ob man
sich im nächsten herbst schon ein indoor
massen event wie das miefige oktoberfest
können muss ich weiß
ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch egal solange
ich nicht mit feiern muss mit den syrern
meine sympathien sind da er bei den
jungen menschen die sich draußen wieder
zu rock festivals treffen gibt so viele
menschen die so
wir hier machen also zwei jahre dieses
lebens quasi verpasst haben
[Applaus]
sie hörten einen unserer führenden
biologen
professor posten und und doch möchte ich
bei aller freude an der neuen hutmode
kurz an den kommenden herbst gemeinden
meist kommt ja ein herbst ist ein
erfahrungswert und es wäre doch schön
wenn wir zur abwechslung mal vorbereitet
reingehen der städtetag wünscht sich
noch vor dem sommer ein überarbeitetes
infektionsschutzgesetz bestehen sie also
bevor wir uns in den überbuchten ryanair
flieger nach malle quetschen ja denn
nachdem nach dem 23 september könnten
die kommunen stand heute nicht meine
masken pflicht für innenräume
beschließen dazu gab es neulich zoff
zwischen karl lauterbach und wolfgang
kubicki
lauterbach hat auf tempo gedrängt
wie immer kubicki spricht natürlich von
angstmacherei lauschen wir lieber dem
poeten dieser regierung es geht darum
dass wir die richtigen winterreifen
bereit haben wenn es darauf ankommt und
falls es ja die seereise landschaft wird
hoffen wir dann vielleicht auch noch
weitere möglichkeiten um dann sicher
voranzukommen
das alles schneeketten und was weiß ich
ja
bei dieser metapher leider schnell die
luft raus
der kanzler nach einer
ministerpräsidenten runde in der
insgesamt nichts beschlossen wurde dafür
gab es aber das übliche versprechen nie
wieder kita und schulschließung ja
kann man glauben muss man nicht sage ich
ja idee was wenn das land hat sich einen
drei milliarden tank rabatt leistet
allen seinen schulen eine fest
installierte zu und abluftanlage
spendieren würde genau das fordern
lehrerverbände endlich luftfilter für
alle warte mal zum wievielten mal haben
wir das jetzt gerade angesprochen
meine damen und herren sie sahen die
hundertste heute show in der vergeblich
luftfilter für alle deutschen
klassenzimmer gefordert wurden um das zu
feiern hier das deutsche lehrer ballett
heute leider nur zu zweit alle anderen
sind corona positiv
[Musik]
34 schüler in klassen
ganz ohne luft hielt
tja so wird es auch bleiben
hat sich bewährt
lüftet doch einfach mehr
das deutsche lehrerverband
dass man nur noch zwei
ja ja
müsste man anschaffung man könnte solche
anlagen selbst nach coroner noch super
gebrauchen die hälfte nämlich auch bei
grippe oder gegen diesen wildtier
ähnlichen geruch von männlichen
teenagern
und wir brauchen das ist ganz wichtig
eine neue ehrliche impfkampagne in
deutschland eine kampagne die den
menschen sagt ja die aktuellen
impfstoffe schützen leider kaum vor
infektion aber sehr wohl vor schwerem
verlauf muss man mal so kommunizieren
querdenker logisch kriegt man auch damit
nicht überzeugt selbst wenn man so viel
geduld hat wie sachsens
ministerpräsident
haben sollte ist 800 jahre cunewalde sie
kommen wir haben die trillerpfeifen um
mich nicht und ich werde ihnen die frage
was sie wissen wollen dann sagen wir das
kleine familie das ist ja jetzt keine
einsatz
eher kritisch mal sehr gut meinen satz
war es schon nur halten extrem dummer
satz
wirklich ärgerlich ist unsere immer noch
riesige datenlücke in deutschland die
briten zum beispiel wissen dank einer
repräsentativen blutuntersuchung dass 99
prozent von ihnen antikörper haben wir
stochern weiter fröhlich im nebel das
paul ehrlich institut
könnte wahrscheinlich präzisere aussagen
treffen wenn es mit tier orakeln
arbeitet wirklich ist wann kommt endlich
das digitale echtzeit lagebild das uns
täglich sagt wie viele menschen
mitbewohner im krankenhaus liegen und
wie viele betten noch frei sind wie viel
personal noch da ist wenn wir glück
haben folgt gar keine fiese variante
mehr falls doch werden wir uns freuen
dass karl lauterbach auf sicher schon
ein impfstoff gekauft hat warum gab es
dafür ein shitstorm die stimmung hat
sich gedreht man muss maßnahmen für den
herbst nur ganz vorsichtig an
diskutieren und immer mehr leute drehen
direkt durch ich frag mal dennis
knossalla aus unserer heute-show krone
redaktion denn es
warum macht das thema viele so aggressiv
dabei sein bis hier steht der herbst
der herbst kommt ja halt einfach die
fresse jetzt ist urlaub verdammte
scheiße nochmal
kein bock mehr auf dem blödsinn ich mich
lieber mit waren corona ja aber wenn es
das ist ja kinder verhalten einfach
gefahren ausblenden ich bringe dir
gleich wasser aus freundchen ich hab
gebucht war schließt sechs wochen
algarve und das wird jetzt durchgezogen
corona ist eine reine wilms frage aber
gerade einen wunderbaren neuen sender
entdeckt der hat mir die augen geöffnet
heißt bild tv schon mal gehört
doch h ich bin riesig vor allem von nena
schink und da habe ich heute mich
wirklich aufgeregt so aufgeregt dass ich
fast geplatzt bin immer im kopf so
furchtbar finde ich möchte jetzt zwar
einen gewissen sprechen der mich seit
monaten aufregt möchte es einmal ganz
hart ausdrücken mir reicht es das reicht
um es reicht aber jetzt reicht es mir
geht's noch genau grids noch endlich
fragt weiter das ist
qualitätsjournalismus ja ich hab so
heitz seitdem ich die sendung von der
ständig gucken so
läuft finde der finne sonst auf alle
news diese scheiße der letzten jahre
eingebrockt haben wie könig und ohne not
wansing bloß in endlosschleife panik
getrieben hat politiker geraten eine
these heute abend ist nämlich dass karl
lauterbach
solche karl lauterbach werden
eigentlich lautet
etwas cleveres fällt ihnen natürlich
nicht ein als heimlicher pressesprecher
von karl kaiser max entschuldigung wir
haben den minister lauterbach auch
mehrfach kritisiert kritisiert reicht
aber nicht mit dem muss man ganz andere
sachen machen dann müssen
schlussfolgerungen also eine
untersuchung gezogen werden auch um
solchen die solche fragen solchen loose
cannon swica lauterbach ein paar
haltbaren nägel in die füsse zu schlagen
so
gekreuzigt dass jesus freiland
lauterbach ans kreuz aber nicht nur die
füße auch die hände sagt wir haben
wie gesagt lauterbach hat fehler gemacht
stichwort genesenen status aber was
erwarten sie denn jetzt konkret von der
politik ja was wohl ich fordere die
politik auf nicht endlich ein für alle
mal in ruhe zu lassen
das lässt sich bestimmt einrichten ich
frage mich nur ob
wenigstens zwei damen und herren
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
hast du scheiße fährt haye